welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of a new
trailer for Loki season 2 coming October
6th with some intriguing editing and
cryptic new shots like one that
definitely shows Victor timely inside of
the TVA let's break down this promo
frame by frame for the details you
missed and we have been re-watching Loki
season 1 with Episode by episode 3
breakdowns we found a surprising number
of new details that we somehow
overlooked before so check out our
episode 1 rewatch and we're gonna be
doing the rest of them this month on
Main new Rockstar's Channel alright here
we go
what I'm about to tell you is going to
be hard to believe
I've been pulled through time between
the past and the present all right we
begin with Loki in close up looking out
at something really bright tears filling
his eyes now this is the same light in
the background as the shots of Loki
watching Mobius making his way out
toward the temporal core this was a new
term that we got from the official TVA
prop posters and one detailing the
radiation suit that Mobius wears In This
Moment warning that it gives 15 minutes
of exposure to the temporal radiation
from the temporal core so this glowing
brain that Mobius trudges out toward
also seen in the first trailer is the
temporal core in the TVA meaning that we
can now see the TVA as a kind of power
plant but rather than nuclear energy it
generates temporal energy by pruning
timelines converting all of the life
force from everything in that timeline
into this time energy and Sylvie
rupturing the sacred timeline has
overloaded the system what should have
been one timeline feeding through this
generator has now become something more
of a chaotic sausage maker so they're
sending Mobius out to patch it and based
on Loki's expression he's worried and
I'm worried that Mobius might not
survive this and by the way this
Machinery that braids the time stream
looks like a large version of the
segmented pieces of Victor timely's
temporal Marvel at the World's Fair now
the reason they have to go back to him
at 1893 is to look for the original TV8
blueprints of how this temporal core
works and that what Victor timely was
explaining to these Victorian Chicagoans
is that rather than trusting Mr Edison
or Mr Tesla with their electricity or
someday in the future Mr Oppenheimer
with his nuclear energy there is a much
cleaner and safer but actually not that
much safer form of energy called
temporal radiation now the music and
sound editing throughout this promo is
just incredible like we hear these
clicks like a dial being wretched it
into place and these female
vocalizations that kind of sound like
they're laughing at us it's going to be
hard to believe and then a straight up
scream on the Marvel logo next we see a
few shots on the last trailer like Loki
time slipping in the TVA time theater
number five and then to the parking lot
of this piranha powered Sports where you
can see Mobius in the background selling
jet skis explaining why our man is so
obsessed with jet skis and we actually
got some rumors that this moment could
be set in Cleveland Ohio one year before
the Battle of Earth so that would make
this October 2022 and then Loki Mobius
in the Colombian Exposition at the 1893
Chicago World's Fair where they will
find Victor timely from that quantumania
post-credits scene and a chime is
minutes then we get the shot of the
actor Brad wolf at the premiere of the
movie zaniac adapting the 1982 Thor
number 319 in which zaniac is a swarm of
demonic parasitic creatures from the
dark dimension taking over an actor
named Brad wolf making them have a
bloodlust for women but it seems like
here they're making it an in-universe
film we know for the McDonald's promos
that Brad wolf will be someone they
detain as a variant and in the first
trailer there's a quick shot of him
crammed into a Time Cube by the way that
shot at the McDonald's will be set in
Brooklyn of 1982 and it's going to be
where Sylvie goes right after stabbing
he remains the music apparently In This
Moment is going to be Moon River which
definitely check out the movie Breakfast
at Tiffany's Beto just understand that
uh it has some complicated humor when it
comes to embrace's depiction of Mr
yuniyoshi but the movie as a whole is
pretty good and the song of Moon River
is a song of this woman who's on the run
and it's a music that plays over the
closing credits where her lover runs
back to her so it's kind of this nice
sweet reunion moment of a woman who's
always on the go Reinventing herself all
right let's move on to the next section
in the future
[Music]
everything is turning
that's right
okay Hunter B15 tries to use her Tim Pad
but Ms minutes appears on the screen and
an axis denied a little nod to Dennis
nadry in Jurassic Park
Miss minutes was inspired by a different
part of Jurassic Park Mr DNA along with
Felix the Cat Betty Boop and propaganda
films like a is for Adam and destination
Earth I went into this in a video where
I think I did figure out what Miss
minutes is exactly remember Miss minutes
has access to the TBA archives that even
rensslayer did not have I think it's
because she is kind of an AI download of
he remains mine and memories and other
past TDA employees Souls when their
prune timelines are converted into
temporal radiation she's kind of
sentient temporal radiation as Mobius
walks out in this radiation suit toward
the core you can see parts of that suit
dissipating from the radiation but to
ob's credit the duct tape that he taped
onto the helmet to cover the crack it's
still intact you can always trust duct
tape now long time new Rockstar's
viewers know how much we use geology and
how long we've been using it for but if
this is your first time hearing about
geology get ready for Blockbuster
quality skincare on a student film
budget geology is a 23-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oilness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you gotta do is take a quick
30 second quiz right now if you use the
code new rockstars 100 geology will give
you 100 off their award-winning skincare
trial set you'll also get an additional
bonus offer of up to 30 off one skin
hair or body products when you add it to
your trial it's truly a while to offer
one of the best they've ever given our
audience so click the link in the
description or go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started so Mobius
takes Loki into the same golden elevator
that they wrote in together in season
one hits the bottom right button of sk7
I explained in another video what time
slipping is and how it is different from
glitching the animated spider-verse
movies basically I think slipping is
moving forward or backward within a
single timeline glitching is where you
hop laterally across different universes
kiwi Kwan plays OB AKA Aura Boris who's
a TBA agent in charge of the technology
beside him is Eugene Cordero returning
as Casey he still has that ink stain
from The Leaky pin in his front shirt
pocket behind Mobius in this location is
a poster about pneumatic tube etiquette
we actually have a clear visual of this
from the art that was released it lists
forbidden usage and punishable usage and
under punishable it lists live or dead
Vermin and flammable materials which
means that both of these things must
have been done before for there to be a
rule about it the most interesting shot
of this promo someone moves a figurine
in a radiation suit down a miniature of
the temporal core walkway and at the far
end of this set is Victor timely this is
the first time we've seen akang variant
in the halls of the TVA I think they
feel okay doing this bringing them here
because 1893 Victor timely is the one
who built the TVA and this would be eons
before he ages into he remains I think
they're the same person and it's just
that Victor timely would better know the
technical schematics of the TBA
architecture the best for what it's
worth architect was the season 2
production title when they were shooting
it in the UK this whole moment reminds
me of Back to the Future when Doc Brown
creates a miniature model of the Hill
Valley Town Square so that they can walk
through their mission kind of seems like
they're doing that here so rinselayer
here in this location is going by her
other name Rebecca torbenet I assume
this is in Victor's heimley's lab and
she's firing up what I assume is an
early model pruning stick on the wall
behind her is a bunch of clocks which
also reminds me of Doc Brown remember he
had a ton of clocks all over his
Workshop okay on to the last section
[Music]
all right
again
okay so Mobius Sylvie and Loki are in
this Shipyard location this is actually
the historic Chatham dockyards in Kent
established in the 16th century
following the Reformation it has since
built over 500 ships with the Royal Navy
until it was closed in 1984. it was a
location shown at various points and
Netflix is the crown in the interior of
the shipyard it just looks very very
cool so why are they here well the sign
of the left of them reads deliu and
sonar and then batpage agree I pointed
out before that deliu is not to dandelio
Marvel's longtime VFX supervisor and
second unit director who is directed an
episode of this season of Loki but
vagland that big jury I know I'm
butchering the pronunciation of it but
this is a shipyard in Norway so maybe
their mission here is to disrupt or to
acquire one of those new Asgard boats
that was pulled by the goats like the
eager or vessel over this we hear Victor
timely's voice saying round and round
and round we go and it syncs with this
overhead shot rotating on Sylvie
watching her TV and listening to a vinyl
record as that TV splits into strands
now Victor timely's voice could be
referring to that 8 1893 Ferris wheel
that was the first ferris wheel ever and
it might be using it in the scene that
he is in as a metaphor for how they are
on a sacred timeline Loop and how time
itself is circular where it goes round
and round but never really changes
location then we see Victor timely
expecting some piece of technology I
think this might be a keystone piece of
that temporal Marvel display from the
Expo maybe his kind of flux capacitor of
his time manipulation technology and
then a quick shot of Loki himself it
looks like walking out on that temporal
catwalk with no radiation suit maybe
headed out to save Mobius and to take
his place in whatever this mission is
now since this whole trailer is kind of
a circular Loop it ends with the same
again line as it begins with like
remember how we opened what I'm about to
tell you it's going to be hard to
believe again and now we end with this
all right
again time being a flat circle makes us
wonder if Free Will exists or if we are
just destined to loop back on the preset
course of history every time we try to
change it that is going to be the
central existential dilemma that Loki
faces as he is continuing to Grapple
with the Revelation that Kang has
scripted their entire lives please
subscribe to all three channels on the
new rockstars Network you can follow me
on all social platforms at avos thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye
foreign
[Music]